Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie, toss a coin to your Witcher
The first half of season 3
just released
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs.
I know you have a ton of questions
about what's going on with part
two of the episodes in Henry Cavill
leaving Liam Hemsworth
taking over the role in season four.
we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos and careful spoilers
from the first half of Season three.
This video will cover everything
through episode five.
There are eight episodes total.
The final three episodes will release
at the end of July
and then it'll be like another year
or so for season four.
remains to be seen whether or not
they end on a teaser for Liam Hemsworth,
or if they'll just wait
till the beginning of season four
before they reveal his face.
Looks like Liam Hemsworth.
Season three is based mostly on the events
of the Time of content book,
which is just the next book in the Witcher
series.
Season two Adapted Blood of Elves.
Then for season four,
they'll probably do Baptism of Fire,
which is just the next book
after time of contempt.
In fact, during the first few episodes
guaranteed, the other characters literally
say the title,
like they go for Family Guy meme,
saying the name of the thing in the thing.
He said it.
He said.
would that speech meant?
Is that Geralt
won't have contempt for himself
by letting Ciri die so that he can live.
It's the whole idea
that neutrality will get you nowhere,
Which Deeks drop references
at the end of episode
five when he makes like,
he's about to kill him.
early
on, they suggested that giving Ciri up
in exchange for his clemency
would help Geralt live.
And he refuses to do that,
which ultimately is probably going
to wind up getting him injured so badly
that it messes him up to the point
that as these changes into Liam Hemsworth
face, the idea being that had
he given her up, he'd still be fine, but
he become full of contempt for himself.
he's just saying early on that
he would die to protect Ciri
because he's kind of like her
surrogate father.
And during the episodes,
they also reference Yennefer
being the surrogate mother to Ciri,
to say, and literally tells her, Oh,
you finally got what you always wanted.
You became a mother.
technically,
she wanted to be able to biologically
have a child, and she had to give that up
to become a mage.
but the whole idea with the Witcher
series is a Geralt and yennefer
or like series parents basically
Just to address the whole recasting
with Liam Hemsworth, since the writers
and producers just came out
and said that they're going to try
and make the transition between Henry
Cavill and Liam Hemsworth as close
to logical in canon as possible,
If you could even do that.
They wanted to make sense
that his face just completely changes,
and none of the other characters
think that it's weird.
what will probably wind up happening
just early theory is that
there'll be a battle
between Henry Cavill's
version of Geralt at the end of season
three with Vilgefortz who
they finally reveal in Episode
five as the true villain
they've been searching
for this whole time,
or at least for the moment,
he is the main villain.
They're still worried about Nilfgaard
series, Father Emperor Emhyr, the elves,
who also want serious power.
Even the Redania wants Ciri.
Pretty much everybody, every faction
on the show wants Ciri for themselves.
But for right now, Vilgefortz
is the worst of them all In the books,
Geralt has a huge fight with Vilgefortz, who messes him up really badly.
Girl gets messed up big time.
what the show will probably do.
Early theory is just say that the process
of healing Geralt's wounds in the magic
used to fix his body is what causes him
to start looking like Liam Hemsworth.
it wasn't clear
during the first half of the episodes,
Reince was who they were worried about,
at least at first,
he was the one that had been coming
after them this whole time.
But they learned that Reince was working
for a more powerful mage,
and by the events of episode five they
incorrectly assumed that it was stress.
Gabor because he's kind of an asshole
to begin with.
And he was trying to get rid
of all the students that are accused
in the Brotherhood of Mages
that had elven blood,
even though technically that would
potentially make them more powerful,
like Yennefer is also part elf.
It makes her more powerful
than the other mages,
but she doesn't have quite as much
elven blood or DNA in her as Ciri does.
earlier in the season, Geralt
found a bunch of missing girls from R A
to Z who had been experimented on
by a powerful mage
who they couldn't identify
in a female mage with a weird voice.
They found all those girls
belongings inside Stray Gabor's office,
as well as the Book of Monoliths,
which was the book
that Applejack had at the end of the blood
Origin prequel series.
They told people how to use the model
is to transport through time and space.
The model gave the elves the ability
to teleport across the multiverse,
even though most elves hadn't
figured out how to use them to do that
they mostly use them to transport
things across the planet,
but a more powerful magic user
could use them to transport
across universes
in someone who's even more powerful,
like Ciri can use their power
to transport things across time and space.
Like literally time travel.
you thought the Witcher was a fantasy
sword and sandal series?
No, it's a sci fi series.
The Witcher
into the Multiverse of Madness.
the book of monologues
just has all the ancient knowledge
about how the magic works
and how you use the models.
So anybody that got a hold of
it would be really dangerous.
even at the end of season two,
Ciri activates one of the models
opening a portal to the other world
where the wild hunt comes from.
really what wound up happening
though, is that it was Vilgefortz
who planted all that evidence
in strike Gabor's
office to throw off suspicion of him
the female mage
that had been experimenting.
And all the girls that the survivors
spoke of was Lydia, who they revealed
was in love with Vilgefortz
and just did whatever he told her to do.
he been manipulating her to his own ends,
just like he's doing with Tasya,
who is also his lover.
So they're looking for it's
been pretty busy getting pretty down
and dirty with the mages
knowing the background,
they had this whole storyline
with the Brotherhood of Mages
also being worried
about an attack from Nilfgaard
because Emperor Emhyr
doesn't care about mages.
He wants to get rid of them
just in general
They're also worried about attacks
from other countries as well.
That fight basically breaks out right
at the end of episode 5 Geralt and
Yennefer finally connect
the dots that it was done before.
It's the whole time
it was Agatha all along.
Play the theme song.
but they still haven't quite figured out
that He's also turned to say to his side,
if she seemed kind of suss
in the last couple of episodes
when Yennefer starts talking about Ciri,
that's because she'd been working
with Bill before.
It's as well like she turned to his side.
but at the end of episode five,
they haven't figured that out yet.
Yennefer still thinks that to say
is in danger, but she's in no danger.
Don't worry.
while that's happening,
Geralt goes to kill Vilgefortz
But he's stopped because of the assault
that's happening inside R2.
And then by Dykstra,
who says that
he should have chosen a side,
making it seem like he's about to kill him
when we know he's coming back
for the rest of the season,
like there's three more episodes.
We know Geralt's going to be around
for these three more episodes.
so obviously he's going to be fine.
it's mostly
meant to be a reminder that the extra once
Ciri thus wants Geralt's loyalty
and right now
he's the lesser of two evils,
which is a reference back to season
one, The lesser evil,
the whole idea with The Witcher series
just in general, that there's no one main
villain outside of
seemed like the White Frost.
Maybe everyone's meant to be
just different levels of terrible
It is meant to be very morally gray.
Geralt and Yennefer spent a lot of season
three trying to teach that lesson to Ciri.
Sometimes you just got to let people die.
most of the first half of the season,
which is set up for the big Garrett
versus Bill before it's battle
that they'll do
in the second part of the episodes
and learning
how they'll go for its is connected
to Nilfgaard in Emperor Emhyr
they haven't really gotten into Vilgefortz'
backstory
on the show that much yet.
but Vilgefortz started
working for Emperor Muir
long before he started his war
to unite the continent
when he was still calling himself duty,
even when he was still in hiding
before he got rid of the pretender,
which he references in the earlier
episodes about reclaiming his throne.
So this whole time on the show,
since before season one
started, Bill before
it's has been in league with Emperor Emhyr
because Vilgefortz
wants to take series power for himself.
sort of like what was happening
with Baylor during the Blood
Origin series, trying to bargain with
the white frost for more powerful magic.
Like they just want more power.
I'll get into the white frost in a second
because they don't spend
a whole lot of time
during the first half of season
three referencing the white frost,
even though technically
it's supposed to be
the biggest villain on the show, just in
general, they do reference the Wild's hunt
briefly, which almost tries to grab story,
but it's like a very brief moment.
So we'll see them come back
in the second half of the season.
remember, though within the universe of
the show, the wild hunt ultimately serves
to white frost, making the white frost
the bigger villain.
the whole idea is that Vilgefortz
is just using Emperor Emhyr to get theory.
The emperor is just
using Vilgefortz to his own
and to get theory for himself
not to protect her like a father,
but because he wants to use her power
to help him unite the continent
under his iron fist.
That's really what he's worried about.
so both of them are kind
of playing each other,
getting of the whole idea
of serious power in the white frost
Every time this first half of the season,
they keep referencing the idea
of controlling chaos.
Like Yennefer mentioned that several times
they're talking about chaos.
Magic as in just magic in general,
which sounds kind of like a marvel
Scarlet Witch reference
because she also uses chaos, magic.
but the idea is that the white frost uses
chaos magic
as well,
like the more powerful version of magic.
And it seems like
they've changed the back story
of the White Frost from the TV show
and the books in the games in on the show.
They're trying to say
that it's an actual person
just pretending to be the white frost.
they speak with a normal voice,
making them sound just like another time
traveler.
Like Ciri has power enough
to time travel through portals.
Or maybe it's just another mage who,
in their quest for more power, more chaos,
magic, lost their physical body in.
They're trying to conquer
different universes
one at a time to gain even more power.
so I think what they're trying to say
on the show
is that the white frost
will ultimately try to use series power
to come to the main Witcher
universe, conquer it next, and then just
move on to the next universe after that.
but that's like witcher and game
like Witcher. Season five.
How many seasons they wind up going.
We'll see how long that lasts.
The difference
in the books in the video games
is that they make it seem like
the White Frost is more of an ice
age, like a force of nature
that the elves are trying to stop.
And that's why they created the elder
blood program that Ciri now
has Originally, thousands of years ago,
they wanted to create a being
that was so powerful
they could stop the coming Ice Age.
but the TV show is saying it's
more like an actual person
who's going to show up Thanos style
and just use all their resources and magic
until the planet dies and they move on
to the next planet in another universe.
post all your theories in the comments
like How do you think they've changed
the white frost?
This overarching plot with all the
different characters on the TV show?
for those of you asking
what was going on with Bobby
Amiel guest starring during season three,
like what is Robby Mel doing here?
Did you get lost somewhere?
He was playing Gallatin,
the leader of another force of elves
that had allied with Emperor Emhyr
in exchange for money and clemency.
he didn't care anything about Francesca's
loftier goals for all of Elvin kind
or anything about Ciri.
He just wanted to lead the elves
and thought that he could do a better job
than Francesca.
The reason why the Emperor had clear
kill him to prove his loyalty
was because he felt like ultimately,
if he were to take over
the elves, the elves would become
a much bigger problem for the Emperor.
Long term.
so, his serve is killing
two birds with one stone.
So to speak.
Like getting Cahir
back on the team and also getting rid
of a potential future threat.
Big reminder, though,
the second half of the episodes
released in July, in reminder
that Henry Cavill, as much as it sucks
that he's leaving the show,
he's going to actually do a big Warhammer
series and Warhammer movies at Amazon.
I've already done
a big trailer video for that.
You can click here
to learn about that and click here
for all my secret Invasion episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
Toss a coin to your Witcher!